do you own a small business or a big
business with multiple locations do you
own gyms bagel stores
laundromats I'm so fired up about this
we have a massive thing brewing with v
friends my intellectual property my
Pokemon meets Sesame Street world and
small businesses like the one I grew up
in we've got a big opportunity a live
event coming please click the link in my
bio if you own a bunch of pizzerias a
bunch of bowling alleys mini
supermarkets convenience stores we've
got something really fun Brewing come
and read this full article and fill out
the form to be one of the people in this
exclusive uh Meetup that I'm doing
virtually uh click the link in my bio
this is for all the entrepreneurs the
business development opportunity that uh
that I've been excited about been
working on for a year so Biz Dev time
with smbs with locations click the link
in the bio and I'll see you soon